monsieur
Grudler madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Commissaire chaque jour des ouvriers
installent des panneaux solaires des
éoliennes ou des batteries sur notre
continent européen malheureusement
l'essentiel de ces technologies n'est
pas produite en Europe il faut en finir
avec cette dépendance il faut en finir
avec cette anomalie avec ce nouveau
texte européen nous allons accélérer la
production de technologie vertes en
simplifiant l'installation d'usine et
donc la réindust
réindustrialisation en faisant preuve de
moins de naïveté aussi dans nos marchés
publics car produire en Europe des
panneaux solaires c'est bien mais si nos
collectivités publiques n'achèteent pas
ces panneaux alors là c'est un problème
nous demandons donc à changer cela avec
un premier pas vers une préférence
européenne pour nos marchés publics le
Parlement européen envoie ici un message
fort produisons davantage en Europe les
technologies dont nous avons besoin pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique
merci gr à parle